hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV
today we're talking with c-span founder
guru eminence Brian lamb Brian thanks
for sitting down with us
you bet Nick Brian in 2003 we named you
one of our 35 heroes of freedom to
celebrate our 35th anniversary and I'll
just catch up the viewers with what we
wrote Brian lamb the great stone face of
c-span has produced more must-see TV
than anyone else in the history of the
medium there's no reason to pick a
favorite among the likes of booknotes
Washington Journal and all the other
c-span fare but his greatest
contribution may well be as first
turning a surveillance camera on the den
of iniquity known as the US House of
Representatives I don't stand by that
those are your words that's right and I
would put you in the list which was
alphabetical you're on a page that
includes the beat poet and junkie
William Burroughs the great baseball
player Curt Flood who broke the reserve
clause Larry Flynt Milton Friedman Barry
Goldwater Friedrich Hayek Wow we are
talking with you today partly about
Supreme Court cameras what have you been
doing to get the c-span cameras the
c-span treatment into the Supreme Court
well I could say quickly that we've been
waiting and waiting and waiting I mean
it's it's like every other institution
of government there's always a time when
they decide the individuals in those
different branches of government when
it's right for them you can go back in
history and look at the fact that the
Senate was closed to everybody for the
first five years everybody you couldn't
go watch a debate the courts the last
institution in the federal government to
open the cameras and I think we've got a
while before we're gonna get there we we
has as an organization recorded every
single speech that any Supreme Court
justice has given since we've been here
in business that they'll let us cover
that's one way we've kind of gotten
ready for it what is the what is the
great benefit of you know taking a kind
of c-span style
transparency to the Supreme Court you
know it's really a very simple thing
it's in a government institution that's
funded by the American taxpayers
the individuals that work there all get
paid for by the taxpayer and the
decisions aren't even reached in that
courtroom they're reached behind closed
doors which we're not asking to do and
it's a public discussion a public you
know back and forth between the
attorneys almost never last more than an
hour it only happens 75 to 80 times a
year it's not really that big a deal and
it just completes the picture that the
public could have of the government that
they pay money to who are the people who
are against I mean all of the Supreme
Court justices against it or are there
differences of opinions we don't know
really there's never been a public vote
they actually I asked Justice Breyer
once in a interview have you ever talked
about it in the court he said I don't
want to be sure I'm calling around but
basically no they had supposedly I
suspect they talk about it informally
I've only ever seen evidence of a vote
once and it came out of all things in an
Irish magazine and in which they were
doing a special on William Brennan and
my memory serves me that he was the only
one that had voted in favor of it out of
the nine it was an 8 1 know that point
he had no idea where he was or what what
some of the problems that people say
okay you know this this will create a
false sense of drama for the oral
arguments and whatnot that the judges
and the lawyers etc will play to the
plate of the cameras is that a concern
or should that should that be a concern
you know it's certainly not a concern to
me but it is a concern to the different
individual Supreme Court justices and
they make the decision do you recent
changes in personnel coming up to you
know Elena Kagan getting on the Supreme
Court we've had recent new people up
there does that any does any of that
matter in terms of this happening or not
I'm only smiling because every time
there's a confirmation hearing that
question is asked what do you think your
television and they'll always kind of
say well on the one hand on the other
hand I haven't made up my mind I'll wait
till I get to the court and then when
they get to the court the first word you
get out of the court is they've said
it's not a good idea but it's really a
kind of a
a thing that happens among the nine if
the Chief Justice would start saying I
think we need to change then the bends
when the discussion begins do I mean do
you have a sense and I guess this is
just conjecture but the judges don't you
know the and they are you know partly
because they're hidden from plain view
they still have this kind of Priestley
mystery and power around them I mean are
they afraid that this type of action
really will demystify their power I mean
it is like going behind the curtain and
Oz or something I think there are a lot
of things at work and every individual
justice is different one of the things I
think it's working is that they they
have the most respected institution
among the government institutions and so
they're just kind of saying why change
you know we're doing pretty well now why
why why are you making put these cameras
in here also you have individual
justices that don't want the attention
there are some that legitimately feel
and they think it's legitimate to feel
that this will be a show rather than an
exchange of views I don't think I see
it's so much different in the court
today than it used to be used to be a
passive institution now it's activists
you've got these justices going at that
attorneys standing there in the well
they can't even say good morning without
what did you mean by that and would you
further you know go into the process
right then they're they're on it just
like that it's a different place do you
think the Supreme Court is most the word
that they're really gonna start having
to hit the gym if they're on campaign
I don't think because if the camera adds
another ten pounds I don't you know some
of these people are we're not we don't
have a screen bigot boy I wouldn't go
there on that one except if you look at
Justice Breyer he couldn't get a lot
thinner or Justice Ginsburg but I mean
they're not really heavy people Mozilla
you you publish at c-span the audio
transcripts of oral arguments and
whatnot what's what's been the pattern
in in those podcasts well let's start
with the over the years audio was
available of every argument since the
50s I believe six months after the last
argument of any term
you could get the our argument and we
did that where every Saturday night we
put an hour on in the Supreme Court or
argument then back during the Rehnquist
court we start asking for permission to
get it same day actually we'd love to
have it live
oh no no live but we'll give it to you
periodically right after the argument is
conducted and for instance Bush v Gore
we got right after that and all the
networks I mean we send a letter in all
the networks usually join us than the
idea it's just been up and down over the
years the current Chief Justice has
basically said no for a long time there
was a time that he would say yes there's
no rhyme or reason to what arguments we
get in we think that this is so
non-threatening that the Chief Justice
would do well but let us have it all I
mean why you're not you're not taking
any chance by letting us have it of the
oral arguments on on audio and there's a
true that the Terri Schiavo oral
arguments perfectly sync up with The
Wizard of Oz let it be seen by your
audience that my lack of response
represents the way we at c-span would
answer a question like that why aren't
the transcripts good enough if you know
if we have you know audio and if we have
transcripts why isn't that sufficient my
quick answer to you would be why then
don't we just rely on print reporters to
tell us what's going on at the White
House or in the Congress it's a new
world and audio and video do I think
they're here to stay and I think we have
the First Amendment protecting us just
like everybody else and there should not
be a difference applied to these two
different is follow up on that is that
ending Michael Powell the Bush
administration's FCC Commissioner used
to talk a lot about how you can't have
two standards for you know news that's
delivered by a print and then broadcast
signals or cable you got to have one
standard first amendment should apply to
everything he worried that in fact that
the problem with pushing that argument
is that the First Amendment protections
historically accorded to print might go
away and it might be more like broadcast
but do you see
is there a shift towards a universal
application of the first amendment and
is it going in what you would consider
to be the right direction I don't see
any real evidence that it's changing
they're always threats and different
political sides like to kick up their
heels on that issue the Fairness
Doctrine in equal time and all that it
is interesting over the years how
anybody ever thought that electronic
media deserved a different standard than
print meeting the print medium and the
only and the absolute only reason that
they ever got a foot in the door on
applying a different standard was
because the original television stations
and radio stations were licensed by the
government because of the shortage of
spectrum that pretty much has gone by
the side and you have things like XM
Sirius radio podcast the Internet and
it's but you have the thing you always
have to keep in mind is you have
regulators that sit over at the FCC a
couple thousand of them they have things
that that once you're ever having
organizations like that you have to do
things and you have committees on
Capitol Hill and it's a good way to
raise money by the way you throw a bill
in to put a furnace doctrine in all of a
sudden you've got lots of people paying
you money for your campaigns in a
strange way the scarcity argument now
that you know the government needs to be
involved because there's a scarce
resources is being applied more to
newspapers because every city in America
has far more cable news outlets and TV
broadcast outlets than they have
newspapers do you think it's a good idea
for the government to get into in any
way shape or form whether it's through
helping nonprofits form whether it's
subsidizing the print media or these
good ideas or bad ideas from my point of
view and I've been associated with an
organization for thirty-one years it's
spent a billion dollars totally from the
business not from government there's not
a dimes worth of tax money in here it's
a matter of fact if it ever got to that
I'd leave
I think the mixing of tax money and the
me
is very very bad idea from where the
money comes comes the the nudge the
power the suggestion it's bad enough
when you pay for it yourself now how
much power they try to bring to you and
suggest that you do things their way it
would be even far worse if the money
from the taxpayer went into these media
organizations I don't they have any role
to play at all do you do you ever get
pressure from the cable industry I mean
c-span is created by the cable industry
it's funded by the cable industry do
they you know what lovers do they work
on you none yeah you know are you just
saying that is that what they tell you
to say absolutely not it's fascinating I
did over the last 31 years I will bet
you that I have had three or four
conversations with somebody in the cable
industry that you ought to do this and
the hilarious thing was the the first
time it happened I mentioned in my
chairman I said you know I'm getting a
little gas from this guy that's on our
board and he said well let's just put an
amendment to our Constitution in that
says that no board member can have
anything say about programming we just
ended that you you have never in 1996
you Tom Haslett an economist who's now
at George Mason University interviewed
you for reason one of the big issues
then was concentration of ownership in
the media you know is that a problem
most people would say it's worse now
than it's ever been
do you or do you find that to be a
threat or a reality it's far better
picture for the average person in this
country than it's ever been I personally
don't like it when I see one company
owning a lots of things I mean that's
just a personal thing whether you should
legislate that or not as a very big
question I don't like the idea because
it's funny the cable industry is just
one example they used to say that you
could only own 30% well why not 29% or
maybe 35% well the courts threw all that
out you know as long as you have the
tremendous opportunities to express
yourself like you do in this country of
yours something called the Internet it's
pretty hard to put the genie back in the
bottle and I think that's the best
that's the best thing about freedom of
speech in 96 when we talk to you
there were various issues that are
laughable or quaint now of you spent a
lot of time talking about the v-chip
which strangely is now in every new TV
and probably nobody even knows what it
is I mean it was designed to use the
ratings program so parents wouldn't have
to care what their kids were watching at
any given moment what are the issues
what are what are the key issues for you
today in terms of the media landscape
and regulation of media well you say
that all it's still to this day it's
still and this is not regulation but
it's still how much capacity is out
there for your programming to be seen in
other words c-span is not universally
all three channels aren't universities
shown on every platform because there's
always it seems like there's always some
kind of a shortage out there of space
it's there's no shortage yet on the
internet but when it comes to regulation
the industry and I don't speak ever for
the cable industry the industry always
has issues because if you look at law as
it is passed it's always kind of a
jury-rigged process it's like 30 percent
over here and you can have X number of
radio stations and you can't do this and
can't do that so there's always gonna be
an issue I mean that's that's just the
way that place is organized over there
do you worry about kind of in these
there's always a constant hum of this
but then it Peaks in every once in a
while going back to the Fairness
Doctrine or applying a Fairness Doctrine
to cable which historically the content
is not regulated or the FCC saying you
know what we since cable is where all
the action is we should be regulating
that now do you worry about that kind of
stuff
well I doubt anybody in government
thinking they can regulate speech
regulate channels regulate content you
can't keep track of it people can't
watch it all there's so much out there
today compared to when I talk to Tom
hazel and Reason magazine it's
unbelievable how much is out there you I
can't even watch even begin to watch
what's on our own networks I probably if
I'm lucky see 10% of it so you haven't
seen the c-span porn channel it's well
it's it's kind of subliminal it works
behind c-span 3 you just just comes out
and you have to watch very closely
it comes through do you do worry about
net neutrality issues especially as
c-span or actually let me take it back
talk a little bit about how c-span is
migrating to the web to the Internet in
a way that a decade ago it was a very
different landscape actually a decade
ago we were streaming we were the first
television networks also streaming in
that real audio horrible format yes yes
I mean it was a puffs we were streaming
networks yes talk talk about talk about
c-span's early adoption of the internet
as a distribution device and where you
say things going now what are the
roadblocks to you know really kind of
that being the new frontier one of the
interesting things about our
industry-based Board of Directors is
that they have always approved any
migration to any other way to distribute
us and actually this estranged it's been
strangely because they've been so
supportive we were allowed in the early
days 95 or so to stream our odd hour
video on on the internet free to the
public I mean it really is one of those
strange things it's a true public
service that they have never interfered
with we were allowed to sell our product
before we were had to sell it by forced
by the government to sell to the
satellites which if they're always been
very interesting to me talk about
industry can you imagine that Reason
magazine was not allowed to have its
content to itself and it had to sell it
to somebody else or if you for instance
had somebody writing for the magazine
you were forced to sell it to the Weekly
Standard or nation man and that's
because of what retransmission rules or
whatever where you as a cable content
providers I am NOT a lawyer I have no it
doesn't make any sense to me at all I
mean I'm glad to have the revenue
believe me because 33 percent of our
revenues comes from the satellite but D
our board allowed us to sell to the
satellite before he was mandated by the
government that we had to what do you
worry about campaign finance laws and
regulation of speech affecting something
like c-span because the I mean these are
clear abridgements of the First
Amendment but often gust up in the
you know in the language of trying to
make sure that political rhetoric is is
even-handed and it's fair et cetera
I really don't worry about that there's
only one worry that I have about c-span
you gotta understand speaking now from
the you know being associated with this
network a place to work it's a job all
that stuff the only threat really big
threat to us is the millions and
millions of dollars it's not been
documented by anybody being spent right
now by the federal government or the
taxpayer to do their own television
about their own institution controlled
by their own cameras it's going on
throughout the government and no one's
paying attention to it so one day we're
all going to wake up and everything that
the government is doing at least as
viewed by government staff is going to
be on the on the web and people might
say we don't need you anymore why would
we need you and as a matter of fact that
well the big threat is that they will
run the cameras themselves they'll
decide what shots they get you'll
journalism will be diminished even
further by that do you but do you think
I mean do you think that's a serious
threat to c-span's type of transparency
I have no idea I'm 68 may not see it in
my lifetime but you know I've seen
things like that happened before you
talked in the 96 a recent interview you
were really big on satellite radio and
at some point you said like boy imagine
driving in a car with a satellite radio
it has satellite radio paid off in your
estimation satellite radio has been
fabulous we have been allowed to put our
product on XM Sirius actually dropped us
from their service and now they're
combined which is interesting they took
the competition out of that which
competition is the best thing that could
ever happen to anybody
keeps you on your toes and it also it
makes people a lot sharper and the
product they put out but we still are on
XM still go into probably 18 20 million
home cars and it's been fabulous it
means that we've been able to be heard
from all over the United States and so
have a lot of other talk show people on
the left the right than the center that
would have never been heard
why do you think talk about the left
right and center do you think political
discourse is particularly to base now or
angry or vitriolic or is it same old
same old and and is it in a good are we
in a good patch or a bad patch for this
I think what's going on in talk is
fabulous
the hard right the hard left I don't
care what it is it's it's it's
stimulating a lot of people to think
some people aren't thinking they have a
point of view that's fine they've always
had that but we act like this is all new
I mean remember when they used to strap
guns to their belts and go into the
House of Representatives and challenge
one another to a duel this is pretty
tame stuff
are you a technological determinist you
know and on a certain level your entire
career and c-span is based partly on
technological innovations whether it's
the branching out of cable finally
cheaper technology for cameras for
transmission the Internet is it really
that are we really following technology
and thinking that we're in control of it
we are following technology and every
single time things get better it's
because some genius engineer invented a
multiplex somewhere and they get no
credit whatsoever for it it really that
the talent you see including yours truly
really would never exist without the
technologists yes I remember the first
time I saw Philo Farnsworth's stamping I
was like who the hell was that whose
only file out yes he had a role to play
yes for sure
who are your let's talk a little bit
about your political heroes who are your
political heroes do you have political
heroes no why not well you know we've
we've taken the money I have them do you
actually not have them or are you you
don't want to talk about I don't have
yeah you know people that watch this has
though filled with hate anger people
that watch us think we're up here
thinking about we have an agenda no
agenda my only agenda is ever been in
politics I mean I've gone through
different stages in my life I thought I
knew what I was talking about but my
only agenda is how are you gonna pay for
this I don't care what you spent it on
that's a decision that the process
very carefully can make or not so
carefully its where's the money coming
from it's the my money is the biggest
issue in the United States and the debt
and that whole issue and that's going to
be what kills us not whether you're pro
or pro-choice or pro-life that's an
those issues are for people other than
us to the side and it's really a hard
here because the government works so
hard at some sub what's the word I want
to use making it hard for us to find the
money where is it being spent
that's a game that's being played -
sadly talk a bit I mean you're one of
the great prophets kind of and you've
been honored and you're in your hometown
and your life and your lifetime of
transparency and I mean this is not you
know it's not a buzzword that a
Republican or a democratic politician
uses but just you know trying to make
clear and obvious what's going on how
you know how the the machine is put
together talk a little bit about your
experience both in the Pentagon in or
you know war Vietnam era as well as your
service in the Nixon White House or
Nixon administration and how this made
you want to you know make transparent
what government does oh that's and
there's a can of worms when I was in the
Navy in the Pentagon as a 24 year old
wide-eyed I I was learning everything
for the first time and I watched this
thing that went on between the networks
and there were only three at the time
and the government and the dance that
was conducted and in the middle of the
Vietnam War fascinating thing is that
the Vietnam War was as open as any war
has ever been but the the government
hated what the media did in the Vietnam
War
they usually hate I mean the government
hates what the what the media does in
all wars but just watching just watching
that process led me to think we need
more openness and all this this is not
an intellectual thing for me it's just
that the tighter it gets the more
misinformation
gets out I'll never forget the fact that
I was the guy for two years on the desk
that the three networks would call to
ask Robert McNamara to appear on Face
the Nation they called it at the time
issues and answers on ABC and Meet the
Press and for the entire two years he
said no the entire seven years that he
was there he said no until the day he
resigned and so all during that period
he avoided the questions the tough and
they were a lot tougher questions in
those days there were he only had one
guest on they didn't have this mishmash
that you get now on these Sunday
programs and one guest would come on for
30 minutes and answer questions usually
from journalists and they would go after
him Robert McNamara refused to to talk
to any of those shows my early
experience was this needs to be not
transparent I hate the word it's open it
needs to be open and I had the same
experience when I was in the next
administration I again was it was 29
years old I worked for a guy named Tom
whitehead his full name was clay clay T
white in who was one of the best
thinkers I've ever known and he truly in
his gut and his heart believed in
openness the Nixon ministration didn't
Richard Nixon and the people that were
immediately around him didn't care one
thing about openness that's the last
thing they really wanted they wanted to
use the Fairness Doctrine for instance
when Tom White had proposed it you get
rid of the Fairness Doctrine they were
really ticked off inside the the crowd
right around Richard Nixon because they
wanted to use it as a weapon against the
television networks to report things the
way they want them reported the more I
saw up close up government and its
interaction with the media the more I
felt that you needed to be have no
regulation because the more levers they
have a regulation the more they will use
to shut the media down because
politicians like to control speech do
you have a politics no do you vote yes
do you do you talk about who you vote
for never how come it should not be a
part of the openness yeah if I were
making editorial decisions every day
here and there was a way to really fool
the public and what we
here maybe but you know I'm a private
citizen I don't have to tell you how I
voted you if I gave my views which I
don't maybe that would make a difference
but I know I've never thought a
journalist really should have to give
their views by the way I overall like
the fact that somebody that is reporting
and has strong views and is using the
influence of that that just soon they
tell me what side you're on I'll do a
lot better with it stop suspecting so if
somebody sifted through we got like a
supercomputer and sift through all the
program with c-span and they wouldn't be
able to draw a pattern which is Brian
lambs secret politics gee have at it
yeah that'd be fasting you might have
wasted money it would be tremendous I
mean everybody go oh wow
now what do I do with it you know let's
you're from Indiana you know Indiana you
think Dillinger you think maybe Axl Rose
Brian lamb actually roses from my
hometown yeah what I went to school
where you played at his school prom no
but I did play the drums I went to same
school he went to and I went to school
with his uncle really yeah also talented
very his name was Jerry Lintner he's
very talented Tom I would say as did he
was he called Axl or you know ball
bearing or anything is a family
tradition or he was called he was just
good old Jerry what what does what
imprint for good or ill has it was West
Lafayette or Lafayette Indiana oh no
laughs yeah okay
Purdue's in West LA be aware I went to
school yeah but there's it's like you
draw a line okay so what uh what imprint
and did you draw that in what in blood
or no but you know if you went to lobby
in restrictive covenants I know you went
to Lafayette Jefferson High School the
people on the west side at the Westside
high school they were called the River
Rats cuz we had a river running to the
town I may never go strong so what how
did that inform you talked a little bit
about how your professional life informs
your dedication to openness what what
about your hometown does that inform who
or how does that inform who you are and
what you do I basically saw politics in
a state that if you were what is that
next we've got technology where the and
I think that's a unauthorised ring time
to wax out of yeah and then it's like
sorry I have to take this call I'm like
you know I'm like Paris Hilton during a
sex tape I never turn off my phone but
no say here yes I do so talk about
lovely epic what uh well as I've started
say bye to Indiana and Lafayette Indiana
at the time used to have a rule that if
you work for state government the party
in power got two percent of your income
look it out like what is I mean even the
Mafia doesn't do that mm-hmm well they
don't do it anymore but I really got
educated about politics from my father
who was a wholesale beer distributor
required a license from the state would
pay money to the Democrat running and
the Republican running and then get
furious when the winner wouldn't do what
he wanted to do and he needed a license
and he loved the fact that he knew the
chairman of the Alcoholic Beverage
Commission and he was this personal
friend and it goes on and on I saw it I
mean he'd take him to football games
with Emily was a friend of our families
and all that stuff
and they worked when the governor was
elected to get the person that they
wanted in as the chairman of the
Alcoholic Beverage Commission it's in a
microcosm exactly what we have all over
the country and I said to myself you
know there's something wrong with us
what is what's the solution though
because that as you said you'd be see it
in different ways all over the country I
mean will you be able to get rid of that
and if you can how do you do it and if
not then what's what's the best way to
live with it I do not have a solution
other than somehow someway the credible
money thing has to be taken out of
politics if you want to clean it up at
all
you know you're never gonna clean it up
it's human beings power is a lovely
thing to have and people want it they go
after it once they get it they want to
keep it they can't give it up they're
going you know and you have people that
are in their 80s and 90s @king leave the
Senate and all that stuff you can see
how it affects you and you begin to
think if you're gone the place is going
to pot I don't know that you know what
reason we're hoping it'll go to pot so
you know that's true and I realized when
I said it that I write your course or
write big drug user ooh
hard drugs mostly no no I'm not a just
the software is this never mind I'm not
married that's directly shut that tape
down I didn't agree to anything here you
didn't sign up for this I didn't sign up
for this
what uh yeah I may well be out of
questions here I was I had something and
now I'm like wondering who called me
it's uh you know obviously I am not
doing very well in know what is what was
the what do you think is the best
political book or book about political
philosophy that you've read what's on
your shelf of you know great political
books I have tried to read over the
years democracy in America by
Tocqueville I've read which means that
you failed you've tried to risk hard yo
you know may emit a lot of it I've read
and it's important the obviously the
Federalist Papers some of that's got
great insight to it I've read so many
books like this over the years I'm
trying to think of the the book that
matter I mean you can go from one end of
the spectrum to the other you can do
Saul Alinsky's book and Friedrich
Hayek's book I think if you're gonna be
fair to yourself you read them both so
you get an idea of how different parts
of the spectrum think do you have a
softness for what is sometimes called
the old write tradition a kind of
pre-world war ii right wing uh you know
maybe robert taft HL Mencken
a particular sauce but this is just
something when I watch when you appear
on book notes or doing the various
interview shows often times they're
people the books and the author's seem
to be coming from that older kind of
tradition and really they actually I do
the best I can to find people that I
don't agree with or don't understand or
have I mean I we try here to get people
who have different points of view out on
the edge you can't always do it when
people get in front of you sometimes
they don't as you know they don't talk
very well or they don't keep doing that
lesson it's right they don't relive know
that you're a taker if I do in fact yes
if I had to define Robert Taft to you
right here I'd fail I mean I I was
around when he was around but I don't I
don't know I really don't know what I
think maybe you can tell me what I think
are there any political figures that
excite you particularly as because of
their philosophy or because of their
celebrity no no I mean I try not to if
you get terribly excited about any
politician then you begin to pull your
punches on him you just treat them all
the same i if I were not here doing this
job I'd have people that would be
attractive in the political system
I actually why I like to see speakers
who can move audiences and you know over
the years two of the best for Mary o
Cuomo and Gingrich that but after you've
done this as long as I have you tend to
watch people who fall in different
categories not a right or left but how
they go how they approach an audience
what did they do
whether it's Reagan Obama or you go down
the list of people and what do they do
to capture audience's attention you
could also go to Larry King and Oprah
Winfrey they move people for whatever
reason and there's no rhyme or reason to
why they do how did you come up with the
idea of us I think one of the
the great delights of you you would have
been great in East Germany as an
interrogator when you have an author on
and you ask them you know hear the
acknowledgement who is this person how
did that come about that kind of
technique I just it's just me I well in
fairness to the question I suspect it
came about that we are definitely the
antidote
at least I always felt that I was the
antidote to what you saw on television
not a celebrity not emotionally involved
and because of that almost exaggerated
this as you would say stone face so that
you wouldn't give the other the people
out there watching any indication of
where you're coming from or it's really
it's taken to the extreme it's not the
way I am personally where you don't
really want to laugh or smile or
indicate wow this you're really terribly
excited about sitting in front of this
person and so that's kind of gotten to
be you become The Gargoyle version of
yourself right I think that's what
you're doing or yourself yes so is that
is your demeanor then is that like the
taking a kind of Midwestern reserve to
the enth degree yes you don't really
believe that to know if you could put on
a different mask right now what would it
be or if you could if you could live
your life over again
obviously you've you know you've really
i'm delivered on your early promise to
live over again I've you know if I had
to live over again I'd be a drummer and
full-time on the road mm-hmm baby yeah
what kind of music would you play or
well you or do you also like that's not
important I would be the backup band for
Merle Haggard or Willie Nelson either
one and and if I couldn't do that I'd be
the roadie with Brenda Lee well I think
we will leave it on that note I want to
thank Brian lamb of c-span for taking
time to talk to reason TV today I'm Nick
Gillespie Thank You Brad and Thank You
Nick
you